it's really excited to be back here at
Stanford so kind of a little bit of
backstory about
you before going into Kay diem but first
a small disclaimer I'll be telling you
guys a couple things about the internet
so for everyone on the internet as well
I will just say kind of up please be
cool and just use the student for the
security of the Internet there are a lot
of things that are broken that we find
out there and it's really kind of all of
our job to help fix them
so first a bit about me this is my
original su ID so I'm actually quite
proud I kind of call myself a Stanford
lifer I was here for three degrees so
bachelor's master's and PhD and my
products complement was I got three
pieces of paper but I only needed one
Stanford card my entire time and somehow
this survived so I don't know if they
make them like they used to but that was
me back Wow 13 years ago now and let's
say that kind of the good start and what
was really exciting to me to talk there
was kind of the stories about kind of my
own journeys at Stanford how they led me
into entrepreneurship and really kind of
share those with you
so undergrad I was a physics major
partially because kind of I was love
math in high school kind of came in with
a lot of momentum and then out of that
became aw of first code term and then a
PhD student doing a large-scale
optimization and machine learning under
Stephen Boyd and a lot of this says you
know this is kind of you know a typical
story you start off at Stanford you get
kind of more applied into tech you do
all these great things and where my
story I think kind of differs is I'm a
bit of a non-traditional twist in the
middle that kind of led me on to a
different path and really led to the
founding of KDM so in year three of my
PhD I get a call from a friend of a
friend who later runs it becoming one of
my co-founders that there's something
really cool going on in DC he can't tell
me anything about it but I should come
out there
and just check it out and I shouldn't go
back to a hedge fund so it turns out
that what is going on is a DARPA the
advanced R&D arm of the kind of GaN is
running first operational program since
Vietnam to basically do large-scale data
analytics for the warfighter
in Afghanistan and the director herself
is picking specific grad students in
academia to come and join this kind of
crash effort because I was 10 years in
the
war effort was still not going well in
schwim and she wanted a lot of new blood
and new ideas so what started off as a
summer internship for three months
quickly extended to me being full-time
quickly extended to me becoming lead
data scientist for all of DARPA and then
nine months later being in Kabul
Afghanistan on a Blackhawk in this case
you can't see it but in the lower right
hand part of this we're actually hand
delivering on many many terabytes worth
of hard drives because it was actually
faster to take a Blackhawk from air base
to air base then actually send it over
the network and it was really our job to
understand lots of different complex
data sets together and give turnaround
time in days or ideally hours to the
most senior of commanders of the war so
that's where my story kind of differs is
that I really went outside of Silicon
Valley and it really just started with a
call from a friend of a friend who I
trusted and then there were a sequence
of steps that kind of took me to very
different aspects of what I was doing
but every step is able to leverage
existing skills while also learning new
ones and we started out as really kind
of large scale machine learning make the
models work make them scaled really led
to understanding what kinds of questions
should we be asking rather than the
specific methods we should be answering
them how do we actually deliver value to
our customer who in this case was Thomas
at the four-star general in charge of
the war and then as a 25 year old grad
student in a war zone how do you
actually have either wide policy change
based upon your recommendations and that
cycle was very very instructive for me
because that was really kind of the
first step of you know you start off and
you're a one-person consulting outfit
with an extremely important customer and
how do you understand the business cycle
and that kind of kicks you out of a lot
of mentalities in the valley that are
going to be more typical about kind of
how you should start a start-up how you
should kind of do MVT if take an idea
around for us this actually started off
as a very very mission driven a culture
of we have real problems of people are
getting killed every day we want to make
that happen a lot less so this is our
first office this picture was approved
for public release but we kind of joked
that this is actually what workstations
look like in war zones in certain areas
and you're doing a lot of different
things but it's kind of out of this
scrappy environment that really we grew
as a company so my co-founders and I we
all cycled through here kind of
replacing each other over the course of
2012 so I kind of joked that I did study
abroad Kabul for four months in fact at
this point I was actually not affiliated
with Stanford I dropped out a bit to
actually pursue something that I believe
very deeply in for our country but this
has actually started out very much like
a startup environment we were back you
know by the entire US military a lot of
other things we had lots of resources
but when I actually came to it there
were kind of all the standard things
that you would have with startups like
Hadoop would go down quite regularly we
would have many many issues with data
transfer being flaky sometimes systems
wouldn't come in other times I data
would be partially lost and in some
cases it would be because a hard drive
was shot and in other cases it would be
that something was up was I've corrupted
but it actually taught us lots of ways
of dealing with imperfection in in a
place where I have not worked harder
where you're working 16-hour days seven
days a week and that's part of the
mission and that really kind of stuck
with us throughout the founding of KDM
and really kind of initiated us into
this start scrappy understand complexity
and kind of base on it and then ask good
questions of that that if you get an
answer you can actually believe in so
that is kind of background on me I'm
going to say it's called kid iam there's
the phonetic pronunciation so where are
we now we're on NSF we are now 40 people
25 engineers over half of us are from
Stanford so this is kind of you know
I'll I'll say the beginning then the end
and then how we got there really what we
do is we secure the internet for the
largest customers in the world so I
believe we're now it'll say we work with
both US Cyber Command and the Navy to
protect all of their network so for
excuse me for defensive purposes and
really kind of absolutely top customers
in the fortune 100 and the fortune 500
across a variety of sectors and then
those by summary we're backed by
absolute stellar investors we did a
twenty million dollars series day led by
Scott sindell because our board and
really more than as a company we've
leveraged our advisors very very well
and this is something that I'll talk
about later but both of damdai at
Stanford and then also a number of other
people really in industry and the
military of Dave dorm
who's also on our board and sandy
Winnefeld who's the former vice chairman
of the Joint Chiefs of Staff who's also
the technical adviser on Top Gun most of
you probably aren't old enough to know
that movie as I've discovered with our
engineers but it's a great movie and you
should all see it and this is kind of
where the company comes from that's kind
of our origin story at the very
beginning this is where we are now and
then if some of you have read it
we now have marketing headlines like
this being written about us and we don't
really have too much control over this
my mom now kind of jokingly refers to me
as a DARPA darling much of my own
chagrin but I want to talk about the
story of how we kind of got from
Afghanistan and doing kind of really
cutting-edge research on very complex
data to doing what my company does now
which is really understanding all
devices on the internet and then helping
companies secure all of them globally so
what can you focus is on we call it the
device layer of the Internet and this
really goes back to most people
experience the internet it really is
kind of what's on your mobile phone
what's on your web browser it's actually
the web application level content this
is know of what Google indexes and
crawls but that's only part of the
internet you're kind of missing all the
infrastructure you're missing everything
that enables that to be possible and if
you look at it about 80% of traffic is
actually not web it's a number of other
categories and really all businesses
have very poor understanding of these
other devices that are on facilitate the
internet and a lot of these have a
number of problems associate with them
specifically with security and for us
what we discovered kind of having access
to large amounts of data and empowering
our users was that if we could build a
data set associated with every device on
the Internet we could actually help
build a solution for all companies so
what we did kind of spinning out from
DARPA and what initially started as a
protected critical infrastructure
mission has since evolved into kind of a
comprehensive index of all devices on
the internet that we've continuously
indexed by actively sending packets to
all public facing IP addresses in the
world essentially every hour and really
our first business case and one day
talking about today is primarily
security there are other extensions that
we take things that
we go off of a lot of lessons we learned
way back in the day from our initial
DARPA days about how to conduct actually
you know research and development to
production ideally same day in some
cases and then also what's what sorts of
questions we should be asking not just
what sorts of methods we should be using
oh so a brief background in cyber
security because for a lot of people
it's kind of an interesting topic with a
lot of headlines and as students almost
all of you have not been involved in IT
in any way and it's probably very boring
but basically the traditional view of
security really is that you have a
perimeter you have kind of a castle you
have a moat there's a lot of marketing
materials based upon metaphors of you
know strong walls moats defensive
mechanisms and you kind of assume that
your network is yours you know
everything and everything outside of it
is kind of a scary wilderness and that
your job is to be on that wall and guard
that wall really the reality now is that
all perimeters are porous and it's
actually much more a question of do you
have this ability are you able to react
and identify quickly rather than can you
keep everybody out perpetually and the
interesting thing about this is that
networks that now you're responsible for
that now affect you you don't control
and you don't see but you're still going
to be held accountable for and this
provides kind of a very thorny problem
for many many people because how are you
supposed to protect that which you don't
know and for us the grand conclusion
that came out of this was really only a
hold of Internet approach can solve
these problems and step one is really
visibility into everything that is
relevant for you and only if you start
from that step can you actually
understand other aspects of your
security so kind of our hidden truth
that our our company is based on really
is that the Internet is now small and by
doing many different kinds of cost
savings across kind of storage bandwidth
computation it's now possible to
actually periodically communicate with
everything and get continual awareness
about everything in the environment of
going back to our lead is one of the
base problems were gaps in understanding
and it was that if you didn't have data
on something you really could not make a
statement one way or another there could
be a model to fill in a part
the data but it would always massively
bias your analysis and from step one
what we really took into our current
business was an understanding that we
need to have data about everything in
order to be able to make reliable
statements about the whole of the world
and really kind of our goal now is that
network defense can finally be faster
than attackers and one-third of breaches
as I've reported in a wide range of
modalities are from these exact kind of
failures I'm going to show some examples
of those and then kind of connect things
up where it really is the fact that if
you don't know what you have on your
network it is impossible to protect and
we offer the first solution that really
enables you to see both what your
network is and where it is even if you
didn't know to look and that's massively
important because otherwise bad guys can
take advantage of those gaps that you
see and again this is translating a lot
of things that we saw that we're kind of
failures force things and operational
environments now on to successful
deployments in in both the enterprise
and commercial spaces it also positive
people if people have any questions so
I'm going to kind of pause and say this
is something that not many people are
familiar with but they're as broken in a
lot of ways a lot of these are exposed
devices not meant to be here and what we
would call these in impasse environments
would be weak points on the internet and
for just one one manufacturer there are
over 10,000 exposures of different
control systems that you can understand
and these control systems have control
everything from a building appliances to
actually the power going into and out of
computers and normally if they're
managed well by network administrators
these are used for traditional
maintenance if they're exposed on the
internet all of a sudden a bad actor can
take and do very very bad things a lot
of our initial projects kind of came out
of DARPA after our Afghanistan work that
really seeded the company we're about
understanding what are the aspects of
critical infrastructure that can
actually show national level
vulnerabilities and are these important
and are these fixable and what we
actually showed very initially was that
not only were these problems
identifiable but that with a couple
clicks and two lines of code it was
actually possible for a bad actor to
shut down about 5% of the Internet
and it was this understanding of both
the large and if you see here most of
these are concentrated in the United
States and Western Europe our allies
that really kind of said wait we can
take a lot of the up excuse me be
analysis methods in really the data
collection methods that were using for
kind of a much higher order form of
protection but we're actually going to
see that it's not just nations that have
this problem it's not just the biggest
players it really is everybody at this
scale that has these problems and it has
these issues and really how we grow and
understand the business just kind of
drawn up this aspect of it wasn't kind
of the methods of analysis that we
wanted to use to analyze this it was
actually what are the right questions we
should be asking next on this data set
how does this chain together and how
does this grow and I'll give you an idea
this is kind of a zoom out picture if
you zoom in and this is a specific
sample this is real data that's been
anonymized for a fortune 100 company
their entire building headquarters was
online you could do things like a do not
have a mouse but if you see here
unfortunately I have to anonymize a lot
of this for public consumption but as
you can see all three phases of the
motor current going to the rooftop
chiller we're just available and
accessible security doors are available
and accessible you can tell the humidity
in rooms on 50 minute time intervals
this is literally by sending a normal
packet to a specific IP address in the
specific way and this is probably say
that much like we came out of a very
mission driven environment from
Afghanistan and from DARPA what we do
now really matters because at the end of
day like people actually can die if this
happens and it's really our job to say
that we need to keep this strategic view
in mind of kind of what is the ecosystem
of all devices how does this impact
security of individual orgs but at the
end of the day if you actually zoom in
like there are hundreds of people that
work in this building and it matters to
me and it matters to all of us that not
only can we identify this and you know
feel clever we can actually fix it by
working with them and a lot of that
really is kind of understanding both how
we create the algorithms that do this
how we create all the technology but
then also how we connect it with a
business sense and actually both solve
problems and and do well by doing good
so
I'm going to kind of close and start
starting on closings with what our
understanding is the internet was as
much like I think how a lot of people
understand organizations especially when
you're coming kind of from University
settings there's these abstract entities
you have kind of a marketing sense of
what they're like and you assume they're
great so for top tech company as you
assume you know everything is perfect
it's all really well organized like I
think this is how if you ask most most
people they would assume the internet is
like this if you're fans of the shows
Silicon Valley there's episodes for they
go into data centers and everything is
very dreary but it's very very
well-organized and they're kind of boxes
everywhere and really what our strength
is and kind of what has inspired us to
kind of go from this one mindset of it's
kind of you know individual consultants
in war zones to founding company to then
understanding the problems of
organizations is that when you actually
peek closer things really look like this
and this has been kind of our attitude
which is if you can actually see that
things are like this and actually make
it actionable as opposed to just
understanding that there's some
dysfunction somewhere but there's
actually a problem that you can fix and
then go with that that's what's really
kind of inspired us at every step
because again this was this was not an
immediate idea that we had this was kind
of a sequence of events where we started
off with kind of you know an
understanding of a mission driven
organization for problems we then
discovered kind of over a course of ways
new ways that we could protect different
aspects of the Internet and then at
every stage we expanded to say what if
we included the entire Internet how do
we have this entire view how does it
start to inform everybody and then from
that we have kind of a number of things
that we can solve but also a number of
business cases that we've built up so
I'll kind of say that there's still a
lot of problems here we've been called
the Internet wall shame that we really
kind of view is if people should be
fixing a lot of these problems the of
the especially started by one of our
early engineers but for us it's actually
the fact that we can take what we've
learned and of have this path that we
went through and then actually fix a lot
of these problems so I'm going to talk
a bit about lessons learned and then
specifically talking people I want to
leave more time for questions but in
kind of my path I really do this as a
continuing education for me since I
jokingly call getting a PhD twenty first
grade most of your probably gonna
graduate 16th or 17th grade soon but
really kind of the path for me and
really the path for a company has been
understanding new things as we've grown
and kind of what's applicable and what's
not I'm going to kind of talk a bit
about these so the first one that's
really benefited me is frequently
stepping outside of our comfort zone and
areas of expertise and I'm going to kind
of tell if vignettes around this so the
first one was just saying yes to go to
essentially kind of a job interview in
DC when I'll be honest I was kind of
skeptical that it involves the
government there was a lot of very cool
things going on in campus and in Silicon
Valley but saying you know I actually
will be willing to go out and take a
chance to interview for a week for a
project that I can't be told exactly
what's there but it sounds kind of
interesting it sounds kind of cool I'm
in second one they're saying that you
know after I've had a couple months on
site I've had some success with some of
my methods actually stopping out of
Stanford because it both seemed that
there were great people around where I
was and that the work I was doing was
cool - then you know much to the chagrin
of both my parents and my girlfriend at
the time to actually say I will deploy
to Kabul for four months and lead this
effort at any step of those ways if you
kind of jumped those chains and said
you're going to go from Stanford and
you're going to be in Kabul tomorrow I
would have been kind of saying you're
crazy but at every step it really was
that growth for me was actually getting
outside of the classroom a lot this is
that if you want to do something new the
path is going to be different like for
example in all of your cases I don't
recommend going to Afghanistan right now
in terms of solving that but you should
push yourself and I think a lot of
forces here even in even at Stanford and
in the valley kind of encourage you to
stay with what you're good at and I
would say like that's correct now
certain sense but most of the vowel
things for me have been doing things
that are different that seem interesting
and our risk limited and then leaving
myself open to possibility
the second one and I'm kind of known for
having sayings around the office but I
really say I have a reality-based view
of reality and I think this is extremely
important in a lot of entrepreneurship
where especially for EE you're taught a
lot of great models and there's a lot of
ways to think algorithmically and think
in terms of systems and processes and
apply a lot of precision and the really
interesting thing is that you're not
taught when those models don't apply
into the real world and a lot of cases
when I was both in Afghanistan and work
at DARPA and also Berkut KDM we're kind
of be simple off-the-shelf method would
have been kind of insane and not really
useful it's kind of like you know assume
a Gaussian and then everything else
works out that really does not conform
with a lot of the way that things work
outside of these walls and that most of
the kind of the best results that I've
had have been some from machine learning
others from just sequel statements
others from just summing and averaging
things I think what's really guided me
more than anything else is having idea
of kind of what's the end-to-end system
and not being caught up just kind of in
complexity that something is a shiny
object or kind of an awesome machine
learning algorithm but that it actually
is actionable and leads to better
outcomes and then lastly I'm going to
say that this is going to be the most
interesting aspect of your future
careers which is despite everything
you've learned most important decisions
are not going to have any any or almost
no information available when you
actually need to decide them and this is
going to feel unsettling but you'll get
used to it over time and I think the
best ones are one being able to trust
yourself and in your intuition to being
able to actually gather much much more
information about a situation rather
than just of taking it as it's presented
to you and I've kind of a quote I like
to end on which is from General David
Webb excuse me general david petraeus
that the absence of guidance or orders
figure out what the orders should have
been and execute them aggressively and I
think that that's really been kind of a
sequence in a lot of things which is
basically stay curious but then also
pursue things even if you don't have a
definite answer and I think that
especially for this class and going into
entrepreneurship you're going to want to
do things differently no one is going to
be able to tell you here's the past
here's what you should follow but you're
actually going to
to figure things out a lot yourself and
it's going to be uncomfortable because
it's not what you're used to doing in
classes but that's actually going to be
most of your lives going forward and I
just want to kind of end with those and
then say thank you well a lot more time
for questions salvations know what are
you major in it what is you in pursuing
grad school you go back you change items
is degree yes so I did undergrad in
physics I did my masters in my PhD in
electrical engineering I focused on an
optimization machine learning kind of
how to scale those out going back and
knowing now I would have done I was
competitive done see us undergrad for
sure and for grad school
I had an amazing advisor in Steven I
would not have changed that but I think
CS undergrad it kind of is been do
physics for a lot of things and compared
to most of your other classes it is the
most broadly applicable set of skills
for today's workforce that we have you
know for my company particular we love
hiring cos people with actually CS
systems backgrounds because it means
that you can actually build something
new and you know how to architect it if
you do a lot of theory in practice many
things come from actually having
experience and you know taking classes
in just algorithms retain classes in
just theory are great they inform but if
you actually want to have skills you
need to actually try to build things and
a lot of that is that we've done
something that no one's done before in
terms of actually building something to
sense the internet so then we have to
think back and say okay we have
absolutely no information on like
chapter 3 what should our KPIs be now
that we've raised a series a like we're
writing that book ourselves so we have
to change things back and say okay how
can people act and how can people build
something of value that's never been
done before well in other situations
where that's happened they have usefully
repurposed skills and we ran out scale
software companies so we're going to
start there
yeah um so amend Whois data
who's it going to be available to like
we mainly do governments but all the
major companies I love those yes that's
a great question so we have information
on the entire internet we have kind of
very very specific information on all
systems that respond to public signals
we're very careful about privacy as a
result of that so basically any org and
this is the government agency this is
you know a large corporation they're
able to see systems that are relevant
for them which means systems that they
own they are not able to see at kind of
a fine level of detail on anything about
anybody else you can get kind of
aggregates about how you compare to
peers but you know if somebody you know
like the classic example is you know if
the Navy asked what the Air Force looks
like we're not going to tell them and
vice versa they're allowed to see
everything that they have so they can
fix the problems but outside of that you
can do kind of a lot of bad things if
you know where the vulnerabilities are
so we empower the defenders to be a lot
faster than the attackers at the same
time that means that we have to take
access control privacy extremely
seriously and do not give out other
information about things not related to
your network of to our customers you our
business so you have a people yeah so
the some ear investors ah how you charge
or what you do um a lot of it is that we
go both for us based on kind of our
costs and the value we provide and it is
kind of a function of the complexity of
the underlying network and also kind of
you know what what our ongoing costs are
going to be in supporting that account
and there's a multi shared strategy but
kind of overall it is you start with
what you think is reasonable and then
you evolve it as you have more customers
and more customer types and a lot of
that is that if you're selling to a
fortune 10 company they're computer
networks are hugely more complex than if
you're selling even to say a fortune 200
company and we have scales that
interpolate in between that and
we work for our customers but to show
them the value of what we provide but
also make sure that the costs are
reasonable other competitor is our
security sector that takes a similar
approach to what you guys dating and if
so how do you differentiate for this
sure there are aspects of what was what
we do that other companies do so there
are companies and institutions that do
kind of internet wide scanning there are
other institutions that attempt to do
some things like perimeter security
checks for us kind of having the full
system that comes together where there
you have both all this rich information
about the internet analytics that
actually show why all these results are
relevant to you and kind of a web
product that I should have deploys
throughout your security operations
center actually having all that hang
together is very complicated so I'm sure
we have you know competitors that are
being born you know hopefully not in
this room but at the same time to
actually get kind of that full stack is
very hard and we do not know of another
company on the market for that there are
some aspects of what we do but we for
our customers they really see the value
in the fully integrated solution
I just talked about you charge based
upon how much it cost in the sunset how
about the competition to do do you look
in detail what would they charge your
things I think they're their aspects of
them so there are some people at charge
based on kind of data feeds so you know
if you want something about a given IP
address you have kind of a query budget
in various ways and then you can kind of
export JSON so that's one method that
people charge other other other
competitors they've definitely more kind
of solutions type thing which is much
much more opaque because you're actually
having bodies built into that and then
you know enterprise sales people kind of
going out and kind of claiming all these
extra things they're going to do so for
us it's a balance a lot of that is that
you know it's fundamentally kind of a
software-as-a-service of component but
it's both more than data and also we're
not kind of doing the consultants kind
of security play which is that for those
of you that don't know a lot of degree
companies rely very very heavily on
services and there's pretty much kind of
a customization is going to be the
dominant cost for most customers that's
not the case for us but we kind of sit
you know in between and kind of
hopefully a nice a nice 80/20 yes what
does the process look like when you send
a package to these in your hands you :
sure so it's going to basically there's
the low level of kind of you know the
dual of the Google question if you hit
google.com and you hit enter in Chrome
what happens for us there are a variety
of different protocols so some I'm sure
everyone in this room is familiar with
you know HTTP HTTPS there's some such as
one that I showed that are very very
esoteric and proprietary to
manufacturers they've names like BOC net
s7 one is actually called Ethernet IP
which is extraordinarily confusing for
last night because it's actually a
protocol not anything else but there are
large libraries of these that you get
what step one is basically how do you
watch and deploy those against the
internet and you can do that from a
variety of ways so step one is just you
have a computer you can cycle through
you know all IP addresses on the
internet and you send it out we do a lot
of optimization
both in terms of using kind of very very
good software stuff from the open source
community others that we've written
ourselves to make sure that that process
is very fast we also distribute it out
in a variety of ways that we can have
very good fine-grained hoof control and
really understand what's going on and
then really receiving the signals back
is kind of you know again take advantage
of lots of different networking stacks
around the world and then kind of
throwing them out is a variety of
different techniques if you're
interested there are relative not to new
academic advancements but there's a
solution called zmapp and there's
another one called masks and we
definitely take elements of those into
our own system and then add a lot to
that and then add other data sources to
those as well but I'm kind of like I can
add a few slides ago that really is now
small it's not possible to do a lot of
this even off of a laptop though in
principle there are a lot of deployment
issues and I definitely want to
recommend I would recommend against
doing that from anywhere on Stanford
Network because you will get a lot of
abuse complaints and your RCC will be
very annoyed at you in your face what
you think is a little bit big way to
gain customers for like a divorce
what with you as the most effective
method for us was actually show and
demonstrate value and and then don't be
specific about that bit like there are a
number of different ways where you shove
it but especially as a start-up large
companies know that you're a start-up
and if you're afraid to give things away
to them you're not actually
demonstrating value you're saying that
they can go elsewhere they can not
consume your product for us it was
really showing people that they have
issues on their networks but that we are
also kind of their partner and a trusted
partner in helping them fix this problem
a lot of this is that for very large
companies kind of understanding
everything that's route that is
important to you is actually a very hard
problem that internally they cannot
solve and until we came along kind of
invented the product category they could
not go elsewhere
so then with that it's one kind of
showing them the value but then also
showing that we're going to be a trusted
partner in this and kind of help you
along through the process with the
software that we've written on you know
in terms of consumer very very different
but in
of enterprise it really is kind of you
know it is a process we sell to very
long large enterprises sale cycles can
be very very long but at the same time
it really is if you're actually showing
value up and down the chain if people
will buy how how do people learn about
your stuff they're learning strategies
and lots of flyers usually I'll be
honest this is an area we're looking to
improve in as we say like we're a bunch
of tech people like I'm not a filthy guy
at all we're starting to hire a couple
salespeople we don't really do marketing
yet so it's been done on our behalf by
some of our advisers what we found is
that in our space it actually tends to
be word-of-mouth that being said you
know this is kind of one of the next
growth areas for us which is of what
does it mean for us to have kind of a
more public presence what does it mean
for us to kind of have marketing that is
honest about what we do and is not just
kind of you know a bunch of noise and
how do we make that in such a way that
it's kind of consistent with who we are
as a business and what we do so the
Martin immersive answer is through a lot
of our advisers we're able to reach into
students senior levels of very large
companies with specific introductions
other customers act as referrals for us
and through that we've been able to
build a pretty amazing initial customer
network and then with government
specifically we have a lot of
connections from our time there and
again it's one of those like who you
know can get you in the door it's the
value you provide that will actually
kind of open up a wallet after you know
some cases a very large number of
meetings
[Applause]